[Music]
[Music]
positivity
[Music]
good morning vayner nation what's good
thursday
august 6th in the building i am gary
vaynerchuk this is tea with garyvee and
i'm ready to rock and roll let's go a
little bit more rapid fire today i want
to get through a lot more guests
we go we've gotten a little long-winded
in our last three or four episodes
good morning dustin how are you today my
friend
excellent i like i like that anything
interesting
um i stayed up too late looking at ebay
there's nothing more fun than really
having fun
and making money i haven't made money
yet but
you have i'm thinking you enter you you
have
if you liquidated right now you're
poking cards yeah how much have you
helped the audience how much have you
put in
and how much realistically and how much
of you because the pokemon market's
selling by the second
yeah what do you really really really
really think like on some real [ __ ] well
you're
while you're doing that i'm just gonna
say hello to uh muhammad
and bessel and behind the lens and
and it's danielle may good to see you
here on twitch chris webb on
youtube michael jennings on facebook
shout out to jay masti on twitter on
twitter
ashley cecilia uh alexa nana
in the building bananas in the building
what's uh what do you got dustin
i think i spent about three thousand
yep um but i mean
these two psa tens right now are going
for
like a thousand each at least so so
what's the net
what do you think oh i don't know at
least double i think
yeah all in like a month yeah so
it's hard to it's hard to take three
thousand dollars and turn it into six
thousand dollars in a month
yeah for sure um the only thing i'm
debating now is just
uh whether or not to flip it like you
said or hold on to it and
hope that it's going to get even higher
i think with pokemon especially the
premium stuff you've been buying
um show some cards people are asking um
i think you hold a little bit more man i
don't think it's time
yeah that's what i'm thinking too what
do you got
charmander charmander ps810 charmander
ps89 these are all first edition
uh shadowless yeah all first edition
shadowless 1999. you got pikachu yellow
cheeks there
yeah i got a red human on there zoom in
on that one a nine red cheeks right
yeah this is a nine or ten this is a
nine i can't afford tens
all right let's get into it cool
what's good man hey what's up what's up
what's your name
uh my name is tormund um i'm a rock
league player
i'm very aware how are things
uh things are good uh it's pretty early
right now but i'm excited to be here so
i'm excited to have you too why don't
you tell everybody what rocket league is
i wanted you to be the first guest today
because yesterday
my investment group uh which i i
am a minority owner in uh obviously um
is uh is involved in the call of duty
league with the rocker
uh but yesterday we announced our foray
into the rocket league so for everybody
who's watching
quite a bit of i'm sure the twitch crew
will know but for the people watching on
some of the other platforms
why don't you explain what it is uh yeah
so
rock league in like simple terms i guess
is uh
you know everyone has a car and your
goal is to hit the ball in the net so
basically soccer with cars
um obviously it's more complex than that
but that's the simple way it's how i
always explain it to like
you know family and people that don't
understand it so how did
how did you get into it um well there
there's like a prequel to it that's like
pretty small on uh plate was on
playstation 3.
uh really it has a really long name so i
could i could say if you want
it say it all right it's called it was
called supersonic acrobatic
rocket-powered battle cars
yep um and i played that when i was
super young and it wasn't very good
were you naturally good at it uh
not not really okay quite fun
um but yeah when rocky got announced in
2015
i i picked it up immediately because i
just remembered that game back from you
know when i was like nine or ten
and uh yeah loved it loved it ever since
and i played it since the release for
five years now
i love it um and so what
what uh what are you seeing in terms of
popularity and awareness
um in rocky um
i mean i mean gaming obviously we know
but
specifically rocket league for me it
seems over the last 24 months [ __ ] got
really really hot
i yeah i think rock week recently has
been doing really well um the rlcs has
been doing well viewership wise which is
always great
and the game's actually going free to
play soon which is i think is massive
for the game in general
um and i'm really excited about the
future and
you know hopefully it grows even more
with that and um
and you know we the people that have
been there since the beginning i guess
uh you know love to see that obviously
you have any questions for me anything
anything i can answer
um i didn't prepare any questions i
could think of something maybe
fire away you got something to thought
over here uh
i guess you you recently invested in
rock league so uh
what do you what do you see in it i
guess so you've seen that you know to me
to me this is like the 1930s and 40s
and 50s when the nfl when basketball
um when the nhl like there was a period
where outside of baseball
you started seeing leagues forming in
other sports i i feel that's what's
happening right now with esports
like it is very clear to me until the
day that you and i die and our
and when our grandkids are running
around this world that esports is looked
upon
to them the way that you and i would
look at baseball or football
you know 15 years ago so what for me
i'm trying to figure out um which ones
are going to pop
which ones have evergreen dna in them
you know to your point paying attention
to the format of the game even like
going back to like
you know when i was a kid you know
whether in nintendo formats whether it
was like the robot baseball
2050 or whatever it was called or like
rc pro-am or just like the car
sport dynamic is always like kind of
fascinating to me
soccer or football is such a
forever global game that for me rocket
league's
dna kind of in football soccer
is um is is an interesting nuance
and i think a very sticky game in
watching
i i've i watched myself pay attention to
my brother aj
playing that more with his buddies than
other
esports games and so i you know i just
kind of like a lot of the nuances
of the game and it really drove me to
being a
you know a voter of yes do we is this
one of the sports we want to expand
into yeah that's that's true like
rockwell at the base level is like
really easy to understand as well
and compared to a lot of esports awesome
brother well listen continued success
you're an incredible
incredible uh talent in the sport and
i'm looking forward to interacting with
you more
thank you so much appreciate you having
me of course by the talk to you soon
keep it moving sorry i'm just taking
care of one issue at work
ali how are you i'm great how are you
gary
i'm well where are you from i'm from
wisconsin
awesome i hope you're well thank you
thank you first of all thank you for the
opportunity to
have me on the show i'm a huge huge fan
um
i listen to your podcasts when i'm
driving
i'm always following your content such
great content
so thank you i'm really i'm really
excited really nervous
before we move on is that chewbacca on
with a surfboard behind you
yes um so my fiance
when i first met him um he had like the
whole bachelor pad
type ordeal and that's all he had in his
house
love it so good all right let's get to
your question
so um so i just want to run
um a little bit of context about me real
quick um
kind of grew up um
not uh so basically
i grew up in a foster care system and
i was about 14 years old and i feel like
my story is pretty unique i feel like i
can
reach out to a lot of people because of
my situation
um but i grew up really really fast
um i was forced out
i was basically forced out of my house
um
and just bouncing from group home to
group home and it was just insane
and i barely almost didn't graduate high
school but i did
i ended up graduating college um
and i was the only person in my family
to graduate college which i think is
pretty
speaks volumes in you know in a in a
huge way
um and so right now um i am an
entrepreneur i just started a home
staging business
and you know one of my questions for you
is just how do you
um as far as like in the pandemic
how do you uh see home staging
um how do you how do you see me
advancing my home staging in
in this pandemic in this you know when
we have all these uncertainties
right now well i mean i you know i think
you just got to get through it right i
mean like the reality is
you can't change the macro you can only
you can only execute on your micro
and what i mean by that is you going on
live
starting facebook groups posting on your
instagram
um connecting on linkedin putting out
content
building a community you know
using the communication infrastructure
of live streaming
and things of that nature you've got to
build relationships right now
virtually so when we go back to reality
those individuals convert into word of
mouth or actual clients
in your home staging business you know
you just gotta
hold on i mean you know when when
pandemic hit
i had to go through a very devastating
two weeks where
we had to let go of employees we had to
restructure
you know banking relationships like it
was [ __ ] hard but like
but there is no other option it was the
reality of the situation clients were
going out of business
clients were emailing me saying we're
not paying you
you know you and you have
responsibilities you have payroll you
have things of that nature so
you know to me to me it's
it's very clear with this disease or
you know this virus that they're
you know when you look at italy and
spain and asia like
you know there will be a time when we
get out of this in america unfortunately
we as a country have politicized it you
know
that's just our dna sometimes and people
are debating things that are
you know putting us in a position where
we're just gonna have to wait longer
which is not fun um but is very much the
true situation but i do think that you
can absolutely
um look for a time early next year where
we're going to be back to some level
of a new normal people will still sit
so sell houses they will need to stage
them so good news
your your thing doesn't die post this
world
and um and i think you just need to if
i'm you
i'm spending all my time on facebook and
instagram and youtube
and linkedin and building relationships
in a
40 mile radius that's all my brain
thinks about
okay and then and then the that's that's
the offense and the defense is don't
spend money on dumb [ __ ]
or sell the chewbacca well not the
chewbacca but maybe the guitar next to
it like
like whatever for me it's like whatever
it takes to survive
um and uh and know that it's on the
other side so it becomes a mental
warfare and the beauty is
your incredibly difficult childhood has
prepared you incredibly
for adversity so just gotta
wait you know just wait
but waiting doesn't mean laying on the
couch and crying about it like oh [ __ ]
this is such [ __ ] you know waiting
means
i know this is coming now let me wait in
the macro
but in the micro i'm going to [ __ ]
make 60 000
friends on the internet between now and
then
gotham yeah awesome awesome thanks gary
take care
bye-bye bye
macro patience micro speed chip what's
good
gary i'm really good thank you uh ever
so much for having me on
i'm one of probably very rare uk guests
for you guys i don't see many of those
uk guys on the show oh we get them we
get them yeah you get them every now and
again i i feel like a celebrity
being sat next yeah i've i've followed
you for many many years
and what you've done um at first when i
first saw
like little bits of bob's about yeah i
wasn't really sure what he did i thought
he's just one of these
inspirational speaker guys it's not
really been there and then i looked into
your history and what you've done and
yeah it completely turned my opinion
upside down if i'm honest you've been
there you've done it
and you're uh you're really at the top
of your game although if i'm honest with
you i don't think there is a top i think
it just keeps going
thank you i'm not just here to get
justin jealous i have got some uh i'm a
bit of a pokemon collector
i have been through look at this quite a
while he's seen it in the backstage
area i'm jealous hold on let me show you
my uh
that's why you're really nice wow
booster box that's a real clean box good
for you me i've got about five of them
in total they're different boxes i've
got
cherries out there as well which is a
nice one that's worth about very pretty
grand uk money
uh my question is about pokemon that was
just to get dustin jealous
um so um i'm a youtuber i do
gambling content based over here in the
uk i'm near nottingham
uh or robin hood as you guys can um and
basically um
i stream every day to youtube and twitch
um
i have affiliate deals with the casinos
which is what my business is based off
in the background
um and um yeah the casinos will pay me
for please
sign up you get a percentage as well of
what people lose that's that's a
business
there's a few of us that do it it's it's
profitable it's good and i'm really
happy with it um
i just want to give you a little bit of
context about me and and then i'll lead
on to my question so 19 years ago
i sat on a wall in the cake factory that
i worked in i used to empty the benzer
and that was my job i earned basic pay
basically
i got that job because for four years
before that i was just basically a
doctor
i was just messing around not doing
anything my daughter arrived and i was
like right
you need to sort of [ __ ] out because
this is just not a lie to live
um i went from that cake factory into a
company called vodafone which is a
massive uk corporation
you've heard of them um and i worked my
way through vodafone
from walking in the door as a sales
advisor with no experience i learned how
to do the job
to be coming in the top one percent of
salespeople in the whole of edifying uk
and i did that in
in about three years um which for me i'm
i'm from a very poor background my dad
left when i was a kid
my mom brought us up four of us on our
own we we didn't have anything
and to all of a sudden have something
was great and uh it all went wrong with
vodafone they changed everything the
commission structure
went to crap um and
i wouldn't say i was back to square one
but it knocked me back quite a bit
is that because because you weren't
saving money you were spending it
because you never had it so you were
buying things yeah
that is exactly it yeah i just blew the
money because it was like
i remember payday back when i worked in
the cake factory and it was like oh my
god i couldn't afford to have a takeaway
tonight it was
great all of a sudden i've got lots of
money i'm like what can i buy
i'm buying everything i can just because
i've never had money
obviously my mom and that kind of thing
and making sure that she's all right
um but the money dried up and then i was
kind of back to grow and went from
another job to another job
started doing casino streams in the
evenings
and uh i was working for a marketing
company money was okay
it was decent money and all of a sudden
i'm earning
good money again um and it's now to the
point where the business is incredibly
successful
i am unbelievably blessed with how it
goes i want to push things on to the
next level
and i know how to do it i know
the financial implications of doing it
but what worries me
is that it will all go wrong and i'll
end up backing that wall in the cake
factory again
19 years ago where all came from how did
you get how's that fear
i am not
fully sure and let me explain what i
mean by that because
when you were just talking i think a lot
about my dad
who i feel because he
also came from zero came here
i i noticed that in his 40s like
he became more risk adverse yeah and
and i felt that he became risk adverse
because he did have an
underlying fear to go back and that's
exactly where i'm at and i always think
about like what's the trigger point for
somebody
i think it has a little bit to do with
ambition you know for me
i'd rather go back to living in a studio
apartment
and start over because i think i have a
romantic point of view of the dirt
yeah you know like i think it's how you
know you
stayed in the dirt for so long that
you're like [ __ ]
that i was in the dirt for a while then
we were you know i was also making so
much money as a kid because i was good
at it
i i'm just not scared to lose everything
because a i i don't act that way
like i would never do something that
would make me lose everything b
i always have a nest egg of like cash
you know just like law nesteg is this
yeah and by the way that's
that's a risky nest egg you know as you
know right like now look
i think actually pokemon as an
alternative investment is extremely
attractive
you know i i myself in my own actions in
the last three years
have put a lot more money into cards
than i have into startups or stocks on
wall street or cash sitting in the bank
yeah um the thing is there's only a
certain amount of these things left
the boxes especially the booster boxes
youtubers are opening them all the time
um i
don't open the box i just buy them as an
investment for instance
i bought a first edition team rocket box
a year ago
for 2600 pounds i sold it four months
later
for double the money thinking i'd done
really well if i still had that box from
one year ago that cost me 2
600 pounds it's now 10 000 pounds for
that box
the prices are crazy i mean look i i
bought 53 lebron james rookie cards
for a thousand dollars it's 16 000 a
piece
it's really hard to do that here's what
i would say chip
i would put a i would keep saving money
maybe liquidate some of the cool [ __ ]
you have
and put it into a bank account that if
god forbid
this risk you're thinking about taking
goes to zero you still have that dollar
amount and that's enough to pay for a
year of living
for you family i'm more humble you may
have to move this and that
i think i think i've always had the
peace of mind that if everything goes to
zero
i have enough to eat and have a shelter
for a year
and then build back up and done it twice
already which means you can do it again
yeah i appreciate that gary thank you
thank you you got it
we'll talk thank you thank you
gary vee what's up what's good helen how
are you i'm well and you i'm good i'm
good
um quick story i was just the wine
library like literally a couple weeks
back
i'm like thank you i'm from milburn so
like we're always there
but i go upstairs and i'm like with my
friends i'm like guys come here i find
this gigantic cardboard cut out of you
i'm just staring at it my friends have
no idea who you are they're like who is
this guy
but i was literally like no guys like
i'm gonna work for his company one day
or like i'm gonna meet him one day
fast forward to today so happy birthday
to you um so thank you taking the time
and
shout out to team gary um you know thank
you guys for working so hard
thank you um so just a bit of background
i am a first generation american so my
family family's from to felicia georgia
um so it's in europe for those of you
who don't know it's really hungry
georgia for everybody's watching like
this before the comments everyone's like
this girl is from jordan no no
georgia former country yeah exactly
um and i just graduated with my
bachelor's of science and digital
marketing and communications
so you know just like every other 2020
graduate i'm looking for a full-time job
right now
um and i've always been super into like
the television social media
um tv production influencers around like
anything having to do with entertainment
like i'm there like that's where my
passion lies and that's eventually where
i want my career to go
however i have had like other
experiences so um just a couple years
back
um i worked off of wall street like a
super successful company
i was a production management intern
incredible experience
i learned so much within the two months
that i worked there for the summer
the team was incredible not only that
but the company itself was actually
phenomenal like you could actually tell
that they wanted
the best for their interns and they
wanted us to learn and grow
um however that company was within the
healthcare industry and obviously not
an industry with my passion um but it
was like my first internship so you know
i was kind of taking any opportunity i
got
and it was overall just an incredible
learning experience
but my goal for the next summer was to
essentially
work within the entertainment industry
as like as an intern
um but also to move out to la and work
out there for the summer
um shout out to my best friend at leasty
pinto on instagram
she let me stay at her place for the
whole entire summer um
so we kicked it out in la and i actually
got an internship
out there as well so um you know i
picked up
and moved my parents were really like
you're insane like mind you they're like
right off the boat like
georgian so they're like you're insane
for doing this but i was like
i'm going see ya um so basically i was
there for two months
i interned for um the social media
influencer agency
um i was an influencer campaign
management intern so i did a lot of like
influencer scouting on like instagram
and youtube um i did a lot of like
campaign management as well so like with
partnerships and uh brand deals for our
creators and things like that
um so it ended up being such a good fit
excuse me
such a good fit that um they ended up
wanting to keep me on the team so
at the end of august like i went back to
school but i also
interned out there so instead of my
internship being for two months
it was for eight months and you know
overall it was such a good experience it
was my second internship
i loved it so much and like that's like
how i knew like for sure that i wanted
to be in the entertainment industry and
just like work in that realm you know
okay um so fast forward to now
obviously just graduated and clearly we
are in a recession
um so there are a lot of hiring freezes
going on currently
um you know nationwide so um the company
that was the better fit
the social media agency they're not
hiring
while the first company the healthcare
company is hiring
yes exactly so you should take that job
and then save some money and then when
the social media agency
is hiring you should quit the healthcare
job and go to la
that was exactly my question like should
i what's your answer helen yeah
okay i have an interview with them today
good
go crush it really good timing all right
good hey of course like what do you do
sit around and hope
exactly yeah this is the worst strategy
of all time
yeah no yeah for sure i completely agree
and i'm like and you're not worried
about this [ __ ] that i hear from
kids that
you go to the healthcare company you're
there for months the la company says
what's good and then you leave and
you're like scared that on your resume
okay i'm hearing all this [ __ ] from the
kids like oh
i can't [ __ ] be i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about taking risks
like i've been working since i was 14
like i and i haven't stopped since so
like i'm always about like
hustling and like just like going at it
so like any opportunity and like i'm
very adaptable too
so you know if like something goes wrong
take that job the industry of
influencers
and like that whole world is going to be
in play for the rest of your life
it's you want to go to la yeah
eventually that's why i did my
internship out there because i had an
idea but
that was like when i was spent there two
months over there i was like for sure
like
eventually i want to move out there so
um you know i wanted like a bi-coastal
company and this company that i'm about
to interview with today is also by
coastal so
um yeah take the healthcare job get
money save it don't buy dumb [ __ ]
and then when la comes calling go all
right for sure
also i have another like really quick
question so
right now like my instagram is very like
basic like sorority college girl vibe
and um i kind of like want to steer away
from that because i feel like
uh like i just don't want to like
motivate people to like supposed
to do better but it's like just so
random like it's
not random yeah i guess so but like you
suggest posting on my own instagram and
not like
using a whole new one yeah you're just
worried about your real friends seeing
it
but like i like i'm see i would create a
like a new one and like just do it that
way but i want my friends to see it
because i always
promote to motivate them good so what's
the problem
i feel like it's the i don't know what
the [ __ ] is random define
random form get the [ __ ] out of here
ellen yeah like i'm post
like don't over straight like you know
and you've got all the characteristics
to not
14 hustling immigrant like post the
[ __ ] gonna happen
what do you think it's gonna undermine
your [ __ ] pretty grid like i don't
know
what oh my goodness even that pretty but
yeah my grade is free garbage
i know i feel you yeah no definitely i
think i'm gonna start doing that too
because please listen helen today go
[ __ ] show those health care [ __ ]
that you want this job and go post
something random as [ __ ]
that would be a good [ __ ] day let's
get it all right see you
so much later
frederick garyvee what's good how you
doing sir
i'm well where are you right now um i'm
in texas
beautiful it's a real pleasure yes sir
well first um i appreciate you for
letting me get on the show um shout out
my family the marching storm my little
sister she's in basic right now at west
point
um but uh my question was
you know i just started interning for a
couple of websites
um it's for the they're two christian
hip-hop websites i don't know if you're
familiar with the christian hip-hop
space
but um i'm a journalist and i'm a
journalism major at prairie uan m
and um i'm basically taking the right
steps i feel like
but i know one day i'll eventually win a
freelance um
journal be a freelance journalist you
know make money off of this right now i
have no problem
doing this for free because this is
experience you know
i love doing what i'm doing but you know
yes sir well then you're then you're
double winning right like
like people are they're fancy out here
like i got some kid an opportunity with
like a top 10 hip-hop artist top ten
and they weren't gonna pay and he got
all like fancy
and and he thought he he thought he had
leverage or something
and they were like cool and they just
went with the next person and then that
person came back crying to me like can
you get me another bat i'm like no you
[ __ ] i [ __ ]
went to bad for you and you got fancier
and you love hip-hop are you out of your
mind i'm like if i told you two years
ago
frederick i bet you if i told you that
you'd have to pay
to do this you'd be open to it if you
could afford it because you love it
so i'm listening so i'm just i'm just
wondering you know what's the next steps
you know once i get ready to graduate
and stuff you know how do i market
myself off to people
as have a portfolio because i think yeah
i think you take
you take all the articles all the images
and everything you put out and you
literally
just cold email and send linkedin
messages and say yo i'm fredrick i'm
good at my craft
would you like to talk to me yes sir
yes sir you understand i mean it's
really
are you scared to do that do you think
that won't work does that scare you
because i want to really help you here
well i'm just confused because it's all
new to me i really didn't think
you know in a sense i didn't think i'd
get this far well listen
you are and you're here yeah here you
are and you're a child my man you're
young
so like not only have you gone this far
you've clearly got the skills to go to
the next level
go and go and ask for it when you're
ready
literally email and linkedin message the
40
50 humans that work at the four to five
places that you're dreaming
to write for and you'll like you don't
ask you don't get you'll be stunned what
happens
yes sir all right i appreciate that
does that make sense to you because i
really wanna you have a blessed day too
but yes i did
like you could do it yes sir
you feel like it's a lot of sense yes
sir i do i do believe me i have no
problem with confidence i do
yes um let me let me throw you something
out because i no no
because i really like you my email is
gary vaynermedia
and you know after you do that for three
months if nothing pops off i want you to
email me personally okay
yes sir gary vaynermedia
gary at vaynermedia and i want you to
put in the title gary it's frederick the
yes sir man
from texas and i'm and i'll remember
because of that
because uh and uh yes sir and we'll do
some stuff and and actually you know
what
even more interestingly dustin can you
can you get frederick connected with
tyler
from 1 37 p.m i think we should have him
write something for 1 37 p.m just to
give him more exposure
yep okay wow god is good wow
god also sir yes sir yes sir all the
time and i've been um watching your
stuff since i was a junior in high
school you know i found you on instagram
and you know i learned what flipping was
from you and investing and you know
um just to you know be here talk to me
right now you don't know how much you
know you've done for me
you know i appreciate you you know
you've talked me through college high
school and
um right now through this whole pandemic
sir so i appreciate you so much
i love you a lot frederick we'll talk
soon yes sir thank you
sir i'm in the best mood
yes sir let's keep it going
garyvee can you hear me very well tanner
how are you
awesome i'm amazing i'm this is surreal
that this actually happened i wasn't
expecting it to
actually work but it worked so uh
i first of all want to say thank you um
you gave me a lot of motivation after a
lot of hard talks with my parents about
not wanting to go to college
and uh they they definitely
they have a certain way of thinking uh
towards college
and i remember just listening to you and
watching videos right after having those
conversations
and knowing that there is like more than
what the
the the paradigm is here in
in in our household so and i'm really
glad i'm super super glad so
quick background story um i'm from
minnesota
i'm 21 years old um when i was
18 and i graduated from high school i
took a gap year and decided to just
taste things
and everything i went to california and
hawaii
and traveled all alone and then i found
i pretty much discovered within that gap
year luckily what i loved
um so i've been playing music my whole
life but um
the same way that you said um that you
love to go on garage sales on the
weekend
and you do that for free and it's like
just a bonus that you get money from it
um i love to street perform so i
i street perform um every weekend now
and uh it's it's honestly like
it's just like the best time i could
possibly have i just get to play songs
for people
and i get to meet random strangers of
all
different variety of all shapes and
colors and everything and and uh music
brings us together
so um good for you so yeah
for the past three years i've been you
know what's the most exciting about
loving that game you're in play at all
times
like i have to wait for garage sales to
pop up
you know yeah yeah but you can go
anywhere and just go
and i think that's remarkable thank you
thank you yeah
i mean things got a little a little
weird with with kobit
but um things got weird for everybody
with kobe yeah
that's just a flip in the radar that's
just gonna be if you're lucky enough to
be somebody who wasn't affected with the
death
of somebody you love and your family
that's just going to be stories that we
tell in 20 30 years
you know 40 years um and i think a lot
of people fondly because they
reconnected with different parts of
themselves
even though even though there's a lot of
carnage the death stuff is not fondly
it's the most devastating part but
if you put that in a separate category
for the people that lost jobs and things
that nature i actually have a funny
feeling
that in 20 30 years it looks like some
of the things you see from the
recessions or 911
or the 87 stock market crash sometimes
that one step backwards helps people go
four steps forward
yeah for example tanner i apologize
um i'm sure you're realizing how much
you love it because you can't do it
right now
yeah yeah 100 yeah and and i'm
so for the past three years i've been
going really hard and things have been
going up and up and up
and in this last fall of 2019 i i broke
the world record for world's longest
street performance i just googled it one
day and i was like
is this possible and uh it was 25 hours
so i beat it by an hour
and that helps um kind of get the
exposure out
because a lot of the time i started out
with just keeping my music to like my
friends and everything
but um but that was a good way to to
get people's attention because like
that's what you talk about all the time
is getting attention and everything so
um that went super well and then and
things started going up real quick and
then right at covid
it all seemed in yeah it's been that way
for everyone so i've been telling myself
that it's a blessing in disguise and it
was this was
the way that it was i mean whatever
happens is kind of the way it's meant to
happen
i believe that so um so i'm seeing it as
a blessing and i'm singing the offense
and um yeah it's still going well like
i'm still
i'm going all in but um my question
what's the question
my question is with regards to that with
going all in
um i i had a couple people on my team
like i have a person that helps produce
for me
um and i have seven songs out now and um
and then i got a manager for a little
while and then i had a number of people
like on my team but i've learned that
especially in these early stages it's
better to just be
all diy just might do it all on my own
and uh
it seems like it's just like i haven't
been bored for like three years straight
now
but um so i'm just wondering how can i
how can i be able to allocate that to
other people because i keep finding
myself
having lack of sleep and and and
feeling low and well maybe not low
energy but getting strong out in a
certain way where i'm losing my
effectiveness and productivity
i get it it sounds to me like the first
rodeo you had with having individuals
around me
you didn't know how to create a scenario
where you were dictating what was being
done
versus having people try to dictate and
create tension
to what you thought was the right thing
to do yeah
and i think that comes with the
inability to have cancerous
conversations and you were holding it in
because you didn't want to have the
confrontation
and then instead what ended up happening
at the end is you just kind of set
everyone out
and clean house but you do need people
around you it sounds like because you're
juggling too many balls and that's not
working for you so i think what you do
is
when you rehire a team when you rebuild
a team
you speak up front about hey i'm an
artist and i need to do what i need to
do so when there's things that come up
that you think are right and i push back
we're gonna go with my way because this
my life
this is my career and i think once you
establish those rules up front it's
going to be easier than for you to have
a canvas conversation
and then you move okay cool i just think
you were too young the first time
inexperienced lack the talent to be a
leader
and what ends up happening a lot to
young artists is they listen to somebody
else
because they think they have experience
or they know better because it's their
own insecurity but meanwhile it didn't
feel right
right that's exactly what happened
that's exactly what happened
and uh yeah i'm i'm very like i'm able
to like
play guitar and like put a smile on
people's faces but when it comes to the
business side of things that's when it's
really like
i'm not i'm i'm i'm still building the
skill set and everything
so yeah that's right i'm definitely
going to like re-watch this and just
really like study this when i'm actually
in those
in those situations so yeah tanner
you're in control
and no and and you can absolutely handle
your business you just need some reps
yeah very cool cool brother talk to you
soon thank you and one last thing
um i have a song that i'd love to share
with you
um it's called sanity and um i have a
feeling you'll like it and i
remember you saying a few episodes ago
that artists should um
push pitch to like a thousand playlists
or more and everything
so i noticed that you have a monday to
monday playlist
dustin get this song get me i'll listen
to it this afternoon while i'm working
and then we'll decide if it goes
into some content or on monday to monday
all right
yeah i'd love to if you want to follow
me on instagram i'd love to dm it to you
i don't have my phone but guess what i
will do that too so
dustin make sure i do that so i don't i
also have to do uh
uh mahogany yesterday dustin so can you
make sure i do that so i'm a man of my
word
yep thank you cool talk to you soon
tanner thank you so much gary i
appreciate you a lot
thank you let's keep it moving i like
the speed today
i like that speed today hello garyvee
how are you i'm extremely well my friend
what's your name my name is sohail ali
so hi lee i love you and your shirt
what's good brother thank you i love you
too garyvee you've changed my mindset
for the better i am uh real quick
i'm child of immigrants uh my parents
are born in kabul afghanistan my mom's
watching right now
my mom shameem and uh hi mom and uh
basically uh bloomington indiana
wilmington indiana shout out indiana
university just graduated from there
uh thank you so much um study computer
engineering and uh media and advertising
but basically gary i've been a fan of
here since i saw you have the cleanest
objectively the cleanest bones on hot
ones by far
and right yes sit to this day and i
don't know what the camera is
about talking about tj you're the number
one guest on hot ones
anyway thank you um i've been a fan
consuming all your content since then i
don't want to say it too much but i i do
think i've
heard uh everything that i kind of need
to hear in the sense of
um foundational blocks yes absolutely
you've motivated
and got me off my ass and inspired me to
create my own content put myself out
there
in the form of my youtube channel which
i'll be able to gain about 600 some
subscribers now
and i'm really grateful for that just
since the pandemic began it's good for
you
really really appreciate it but uh
basically uh my question for you is uh
because you know you talked a lot about
voiced and how you you were right about
that voice taking over everything
and you know we're i think we're already
in 5g
and ai coming up and i'm just wondering
where you see that impact in
communication
advertising the realm that you're in oh
i mean look i think we are at like
i think the last decade of the internet
has
given rise to video on
layered on the internet the the
infrastructure is incredible what you
and i are doing right now is but you
know i'm old you're a youngster like
the idea of me in new york you and
indiana this clean this many people
watching as
infrastructure for free are you out of
your mind like that's
foreign talk 20 years ago i think that
i think that us walking around our house
in 20 years
saying alexa or apple or facebook or
something else or google or whoever wins
the voice games or probably four to five
companies that are in the voice game
and being the remote control of all of
our activities like i don't want to go
to my seamless or post mates app i just
want to say
alexa order me a pizza and then it says
which one and i'm like well what's the
hottest pizza right now in the city and
it's replying like i don't think people
understand
how big of a deal what the 5g
lack of like lag and the voice pipes
of the ai around recognizing
you know human language and i mean i
just think the pipes
of voice are going to be so substantial
you know for example i have a search
engine right now
um i don't know you know about this oh
yeah so dustin put this in here i think
it's going to blow a lot of people's
mind because i haven't really promoted
anything
crazy search.garyvaynerchuk.com
you can literally type in any word and
it will take you directly to where i'm
talking about that
if you know which is just unbelievable
right and i'm very proud of the team and
big shout out to the team and we i'm
really proud of it
however one of the reasons i built it is
in six years when you're walking by and
be like
hey alexa what did garyvee or with the
way that world's gonna work i think it's
gonna be like
hey garyvee what do you think about
patience and i just start talking
you know like i don't think people
understand where this is going
i used to have to go to the library to
look up
who the 29th president of spain was i
can get that in 40 seconds now
you know like you know and so i just
don't think that people
get how big of a deal it is and i can't
wait and
and i'm building a library of
information
to then be able to layer on those pipes
which will bring more awareness
and most importantly more value yeah
absolutely
and um that's awesome and the reason i
was able to get on is because you pinned
my comment shouting out
vayniacs in one of your older posts
shout out to all the vayniacs the og
garyvee fans that's
before i'm not gonna lie as before when
i caught you you were like six
when i was like maniacs maniacs we got
we got to bring it back we got to bring
that back
um but i do really appreciate it and i
mean shout out to your team
shout out to dustin shout out zayn uh
who got me on uh shout out to everyone
who you've curated around you
uh drock uh shout out babin tyler
everyone who i've had
at interactions would have been nothing
but kind and you you've
really taught me you know empathy and
gratitude and that's really what i've
been leading with and i'm very happy
because of it
garyvee and i hope today i can't wait to
hug in person brother i know it will
happen
absolutely can we get out i want to get
a picture with you real quick we both
just
all right i'll screen cap that thanks so
much
thank you
esther how are you you're a mute okay
i'm not
mute now how are you oh um i'm pretty
excited to meet you
it's really cool thank you where are you
right now
i'm in los angeles 6 46 a.m here
i'm i'm impressed thank you for getting
up early
so so what's cooking what can i answer
for you yeah so i'll give an intro about
me so my primary job is in tech
but my side hustle is being a dj like i
would not leave
tech because i love it too but who i
aspire to be is like david solomon he's
cl goldman sachs he's also a dj producer
elon musk has started to produce good
music too so during this pandemic i've
been like building my
brand on twit twitch tick tock um
it but while djing started out as a
hobby and
i started to monetize off it and i felt
like it was more
work than more fun like i started to see
like oh my gosh it's such a chore
setting up i
hate setting up so i was just wondering
what your thoughts are
on that i've got real thoughts on it i
think that you should
stop monetizing it oh
stop sizing it's okay it's okay
to not monetize it like i mean i leave
money
i leave money on the table in a million
ways because
i don't like it
like like you know the money's just not
worth it if you took something you loved
actually i got a great story for you and
it has to do with this
one of the riskiest scariest things i've
done in business
in the last 30 years was when my brother
and i started vaynersports
and we started representing football
players because my one
escapism was new york jets football no
matter what
on those sundays during the nfl draft
during free agency
no matter how much pressure and
negativity i had going on
i would escape into this universe and it
would be so happy
and i was scared that us getting into
the business
would turn it into a business and i
wouldn't enjoy it
luckily and i was prepared i even told
aj said hey i'll do that we'll do this
but
i may not want to do this in a year
because if i start watching jet games
and start rooting for vayner sports
players over the jets it's going to ruin
this thing for me
luckily i love the jets so much that i
don't even care when they play vayner
sports players i hate the vayner sports
players
because i love the jets so much i'm so
tribal about it so it didn't
but i was prepared to like lose money
and not do it anymore because i
cherished my happiness for you you love
tech and you're a professional in it
and you have a lot of upside you need to
really give thought to not monetizing
the dj stuff because it might be
contaminating
your happiness and and here's where it
gets really important
this is a very important nuance you
being able to escape into dj world
allows you to be more successful in tech
world
so you might be actually losing money
because you're monetizing on djing but
it's corroding that escapism which
doesn't make you as effective in your
core business
and career which may limit that upside
so you're throwing off the balance so
even though you're monetizing the dj
monies you might actually losing money
because you've limited the
upside of you on the tech side i
completely believe that my professional
success
is predicated on my ability to escape to
places like garage sailing
sports cards you know other interests
and that gives me the fuel to be
such a juggernaut in what i do for a
living so i would protect
the purity of that djing at all cost
[ __ ]
stop monetizing that's very true
make sense yeah but i also want to ask
like
how do i stop obsessing over like the
viewers the followers the subscription
subscribers you know on twitch
i i think that
it all depends on your relationship with
your own self-esteem
and basically the way you played junior
high in high school the biggest thing
that
people what people don't realize is what
social media and subscribers have
done is it's extended high school
dynamics
into grown-up life it's a popularity
contest
oh yeah and i think that people need to
i mean i'm a huge proponent and i'm
somebody who's gotten tens of millions
of followers across all these platforms
i'm a huge proponent of hiding
follow counts across the board
it would it would look on paper that it
would be
not beneficial for me to be the champion
of that but i
just want more happiness and i do not
believe that
the following count numbers are bringing
happiness i think it's bringing anxiety
now i don't think that's youtube and
instagram and tick tock's fault i think
that's the human's fault
yeah i i you know the way for you to
stop obsessing
is by stop obsessing and what i mean by
that esther is that
you need to realize that you just love
the djing so much
it's almost irrelevant if anybody's
watching for example
i was garage sailing for the last 25
years
i don't do garage sale videos and flip
content for my social
i just happened to document something i
always did nobody was watching me nobody
gave a [ __ ]
i just loved it so i don't care if it
does well or it doesn't do well my
sports card
videos on my instagram don't do as well
as my other stuff
i just don't give a [ __ ]
okay that makes sense happiness over
everything okay so self-care and
happiness over everything
over everything it just doesn't matter
like
like like the market always
underestimates people like do not use
that
as affirmation you know there
if you just do it because you love doing
it a lot of the things that you want to
happen will happen
or you'll realize hey there's just a lot
of people that are way better at beach
blue
i i love playing basketball
there's probably four billion people
that are better at basketball than me
but that doesn't stop me
from playing basketball and and i think
too many people right now
are like well i only have 8 000
followers well guess what you weren't
meant to be beyonce
you weren't meant to be marshmallow you
know or avicii and that's
super fine because you're doing it
because you [ __ ]
actually love it like that's more than
enough
you're right yeah
that i wish you nothing but success
thank you wait can i ask one more
question yes go ahead
okay so you know in a djing side like it
goes hand in hand with alcohol
and i know maybe this isn't a question
for you but
i find it more fun to stream while
drinking but i really want to
separate the two is that funny it's a
real problem
is that a problem are you getting
blackout drunk or are you just getting a
little loose and having fun
um half honestly listen
you know i'm not i'm not sure i'm
equipped to handle like like
true like like like substance abuse but
like
look i think look look having fun
is something you need to put on a
pedestal you know
if you're doing in the confines of your
home and you're not endangering anybody
or more importantly yourself and putting
yourself in the curious spots
i think the question becomes are you
using that
to disguise your insecurity while you're
doing it is a very important question
maybe
[Laughter]
that okay
listen to me yes sir if you can get a
relationship with the judgment of others
and you take down the value of other
people's voice
and you take up the value of your own
voice you will be blown away by how much
better life
starts [ __ ] clicking thank you you
sound like my
[Laughter]
have a therapist day all right thank you
so much
you know what dustin i think we're gonna
wrap with that because i have a big uh
meeting i gotta prep for a little bit
and i just need these six minutes that
was a good one can we clip that i think
that one it's
just gonna help a lot of people there's
a lot of things i don't know what the
[ __ ] we're gonna name it
but it's me and me and dj woo-woo uh
choppin
um everybody please please please share
squad
hope you share this hope people get on
dustin are we live tomorrow
i believe so um
because yeah we are and do we have urls
that people can rsvp for like
like to me the thing i'm trying to
figure out is how to get this incredible
nation
to recruit more people in the debut
force there's like a bigger watch party
at 9am like
like but then we did we rsvp with with
facebook and then
it was [ __ ] up can we do youtube like
where are we at i thought youtube we can
do that and it's working can
can we get our [ __ ] together as a team
so that like for example we have an epic
episode like this
everyone gets motivated and i could say
like bring four friends tomorrow
and there's actually like a url instead
of like oh just look for gary's
social pop-up like we need to figure
that out like in a much more functional
operational way
uh someone suggested if you could well
like this person was
specifically asking for linkedin and
they asked if you could just send the
community text out with the link
um you mean the community text like text
everybody through
my two one two nine three one five so
everyone yeah i just don't wanna bother
everybody you know what yeah actually we
should start
a push notification url you know
sub group on community you know how we
do the hashtag thing talk to jim
let's definitely do that but i think i
think we need to do a better job but
like
hey everybody let's uh let you know in a
ghetto way
in a scrappy way in a dirt way please
get a viewing party for tomorrow's
show and then in the comments section
tell me how you did it what did you use
i do think dustin we can set up a
youtube url right
he didn't seem very confident with that
response yeah
i mean we have a youtube yeah we have
good to do tomorrow tomorrow can you
can you uh stage up the hot ones episode
to end when i end yeah tomorrow because
i think a lot of people haven't seen it
they should
the whole thing yes okay
it's like 30 minutes
explain to me which part of this you
don't think people are going to watch it
or you don't want to do the work to prep
it
no um i just don't know if people are
going to watch it
but i also don't i have to figure out
how i can actually stream it because
that's the part you're actually saying
because your first answer you know is
ludicrous [ __ ]
you're gonna watch it all right i'll
figure it out
what do you think we're doing around
here you're right you're right
figure it out bro see ya bye everyone
hit me up on twitter right now i'm
prepping for three minutes and i just
want to see what everybody's love is
garyvee on twitter no question the place
where i interact the most if you've not
signed up for twitter you're making a
huge mistake
gary vee i'll see ya